in terms of doing therapy psychotherapy
what does the successful interaction
look like perhaps a fun question uh
perhaps not uh what do you think of the
psychiatrist Sean and Goodwill Hunting
played by Robin Williams
so what is the full range of interesting
interactions can there be an intimacy of
friendship a kind of
um varied interaction that kind of
Blends the lines of you know 30 minutes
session once a week or whatever versus
like a really kind of
deliberate long-term project that cares
about the well-being of a person across
the months and years
or as though what can you say about a
successful
interaction between therapist and
patient I think we're much better served
by the latter
right and again it doesn't have to be
over years we maybe person doesn't
person might need that over weeks they
might need it over months they might
need it over years but if I'm
understanding correctly you're
describing something that is like a real
human engagement yeah right and I work
in a field that for years and years and
years the patient didn't get to see the
therapist was sitting in a place sitting
behind the person right so that's not of
course the only tradition and there are
aspects of that tradition that can be
very humanized but the idea that we're
supposed to not be human I mean this
medicine is shot through with this right
that the doctor's supposed to be God and
it protects the doctor and that makes
its way into therapy and the idea of the
superiority the therapist knows more
um I mean in some ways
yes but the idea is like to know more
about mechanical things like right to
know more about like facts and knowledge
not as a human being right if we
approach therapy as a collaborative
human endeavor right where if we're
going to do it together of course I'm
going to learn from you too right I mean
we're two human beings and we're talking
about things that are deep and personal
and intimate and and I'm don't want I'm
not going to participate in a way that
makes it like about me as much as it's
about you but we're two humans and
what's gone on in me may have relevance
and sharing it may have relevance and at
times you doing something back for me
may have relevance I'll give you an
example of a person who would not let me
help him it was a young man so when I
was in training who was very very sick
and needed to change certain choices and
habits or he was not going to survive
and I had no ability to help him
whatsoever and I went and I saw a
supervisor who is existentially trained
where here it's different from
existentialism in the classic sense but
it's about really human connection right
and the guy was always wanting to teach
me something right because I I can get
by in Spanish but he was fluent in
Spanish and he and he wanted to he'd oh
you traveled here and he'd say you know
a word to see if I knew and I was always
directing back to what I was supposed to
do right and the supervisor I've never
forget he said let him teach you Spanish
like okay come on so we had a couple
sessions where if you look from the
outside you say what is going on there
like right like this it was they were
Spanish lessons yeah to me right yeah
and then at some point he brought in his
mother and it was he hadn't brought her
in yet and he he was in part showing off
that he taught me something right and I
said a couple things and he felt more
powerful like he was younger than me and
he felt sick and disempowered but he
didn't feel that way once he taught me
something and we showed it off to his
mother right and his behavior started to
change he started taking better care of
himself he could see a little more what
I was saying he's like you're a
wonderful person look you love your
mother and your aunt and they love you
and like look he could start seeing that
about himself self but that came from
humanness and and I think that's the way
we help people I don't understand why we
don't do everything that way it's like
we're two humans but if you're doing
something for me then there's something
you have an expertise and I don't that's
why you're doing it for me the reverse
could be true but it doesn't mean we're
not just two humans doing something
together and the healthcare system and
the legal system should not get in the
way of that I mean there's liability and
all these kinds of things that um
can get in the way of the humanness
right I mean some of that is Justified
you have to be careful you have to make
sure there's of course or irresponsible
but
a little too much can destroy the
humanness I'll use a weirdo you usually
you say something is insane like it's
not consistent with sanity yeah and the
presence of the legal system look I'm
all for of course Physicians have to be
held we have to be responsible and
everybody makes mistakes and people to
be accountable for their mistakes
um I understand all of that but what we
see now it's so
absurd that oh like everyone is
frightened right everyone is frightened
and then just looking to like how do I
slot into the box check the check the
boxes of what I'm supposed to do and not
get in trouble you know people get sued
because someone was at that hospital and
that doctor touched their care this
happens in the VA system it happens in
other systems too so you might have
touched their care and no one's even
saying you did anything wrong but they
say the next person did oh someone
settled on your behalf and now you have
a malpractice Ding and maybe you can't
get a license somewhere else like
doctors are terrified and they're
terrified for good
they're terrified for good reason
because the same society that has given
doctors in many ways too much power over
time and and treated doctors maybe too
much like Gods now is I think enacting
some of society's anger and envy out on
the Physicians even the idea that like a
person would know what medicine like I
saw a couple TV commercials give me this
it's like it's interesting right
because even if let's say I take myself
out of it doesn't feel good obviously
but it takes about it's like wow like I
went to school for like eight years for
this and you don't even want to hear my
opinion right you're not taking good
care of yourself right it doesn't mean
you should think my opinion is gospel
because I said it but but people then
don't have an understanding of like what
is expertise what do people learn how
can people help us understand and make
better decisions it kind of goes out
with the wash and then the the the the
position of the expert I mean it's a lot
has been written about this right gets
diminished over time very much to our
own Peril and then often with aggression
in the medical world coming back towards
the alleged expert
yeah expertise is a tricky one such a
such a tricky thing because uh
coupled with expertise can the the
attention is this arrogance that can
come with expertise right the arrogance
can make the the expert feel like
they're more of an expert
um and there's a vicious cycle and then
the arrogance in in the current in the
21st century especially with the
internet the arrogates can uh completely
Force the public to distrust the expert
because it all they sees to get
arrogance versus the expertise so
um ultimately you have to have I think
um the the greatest experts and Masters
I know are are the ones that have uh
complete humility right humility and
gratitude and gratitude he's just back
which is usually a really good sign that
somebody
is at the top of their field
right and they'll acknowledge that they
don't know everything right which is
hilarious right so like the the the the
the best experts I know are the ones
that will
say that they don't know right they
would not call themselves the next
person right right it's very confusing
right or know that they know a lot but
don't know the answer to this you see
that a lot in medicine that person knows
they're an expert surgeon but they also
acknowledge they don't know if this is
the right time to operate that's how you
get to the best answer instead of
someone who is an expert and always
knows the answer